so I've been banned from an event now
the organizer told me was about a video
I did about trans people and knowing our
catalog we've only done two videos about
trans people
what about yeah only two one about the
sports oh yes and one about not wanting
to date a transgender person yes and so
this transgender people in sports I mean
most feminists agree with what we're
saying so I thought it was that one so
I'm gonna just assume it was the one
where we stood first I get in flat which
was yes so there's a lot of that really
agree with what we're saying sure but I
don't want to rely on that argument
because it's black people that agree
with you so we can't rely on that
let's not want the D trans people it's
not something that we've been shouting
out at the top of her lungs her whole
life I've said it once in my life and
that was during that video and the only
reason I said it in that video was
because Riley was accusing anybody who
wasn't interested of being transphobic
because what I've come to realize is
that a lot of times people are trying to
shame you into agreeing with the shame
you and if they can't shame you they
want to ostracize you from the overall
tribe that is the two things that they
enjoy doing it's why when someone is
having a speech they don't like they
bang loud drums and they draw they drown
it out when someone is saying something
they dislike they try to have that
person immediately bad so it doesn't
allow for any form of discourse it just
allows for alienation and here's why
this is extremely important and why I
think everybody should be listening to
what we're saying is that if you haven't
heard recently people between the ages
of 18 to 34 or actually now less
accepting of LGBTQ people than they wore
over a year ago and this dropped by over
8% so what does that mean that that you
know there's always this mantra that
young people aren't handily going to be
more and more liberal in other words but
we're actually seeing the opposite thing
being true and so I would tell people
part of why I think this isn't becoming
true is that people are seeing some of
the tactics that LGBTQ activists are
using in order to further their agenda
and when you're seeing these things like
ostracizing denying people the ability
to speak only allowing certain types of
voices to be heard you are then making
sure that people who are young who want
to explore ideas or no longer feeling
comfortable and you're not the same
thing that was done to you that's ironic
the ironic part is not so much as you're
doing that but you're using the same
tactics as your oppressors sure and even
within the LGBTQ community I mean the my
stance is not that extremes a lot of
queer people who are not interested in
dating trans people there are a lot of
trans people who don't want to date
trans people and this is not to shame
them this is not to say they're
undesirable they're just not what I want
and further and I just thought it was
very interesting that on a panel for hip
hop is misogynistic which is what I was
gonna participate in uh they only had
clear artists for the most part they
banned me for having an opinion that 95%
of men and half meaning 95% of men do
not want to date a trans person then you
are saying that all these men are
inherently transphobic and have some
irrational fear or maybe there's a
diverse reasons there's a diverse
spectrum of reasons as to why men may
not want to date a certain subset of
group people well you never know you're
not let people speak no not a thing that
happen is that we're not saying that
people should not be alive and and I've
heard that an argument do you know what
it feels like to fight for your
existence fight for your existence I did
not tell you that you have to cease to
exist at all
oh that is not the case and that's not
what we're going at all do you know what
it asked we have to fight for your exist
in the live your life not only view
that you know what we're all for your
equal rights yes should be not
discriminated against in the workplace
and all the other facets in which human
beings live but when it comes to dating
people are allowed to have their
preference ladies you want to not date
short men don't date short men but a
tease you want a date man with a certain
income level date those men many of you
don't want to date trans people don't
they check if you do want a black people
don't a black people they whatever you
wanna do but help tell people that they
have some kind of irrational feel
because they don't want to date with a
certain subset of groups to me is
illogical because what people look for
in dating is so varied and the reasons
are so varied that for me it's so
small-minded of you to inherently reduce
someone to some phobia when in reality
you don't know their lived experience so
you want to be seen as individuals you
want to be seen as real human beings but
then you strip people of their
individuality and of the humanity when
they will show reasonings that you don't
understand we can pass all the laws but
what we cannot do is legislate
and I think deep down more than a
lobbying path we want our neighbors in
the people around us to look at us with
empathy and respect and you are not
going to get it if you don't allow
people to speak if you don't allow
people to be in prison if you don't
allow for ideas I don't drive with your
world vision that to me
someone said yeah okay I understand your
point but why did you have to say why
did I have to say my point so why was
she allowed to say her point I'm Tom not
able to say my point which what are you
talking about who is you like your
understand my point but what do you have
to say it
what what so sometimes their argument
isn't even that you're wrong your
argument is that you're right it goes
it's a you shouldn't say it out loud
because it hurts some people no that's
not how the world works boo-boo that's
not how the world works and that's not
how we're gonna advance anything anyways
and I think they're hurting me or
hurting you hurting people when they do
this but every time that these activists
have come out against somebody those
people have gotten more and more reached
in fact I think Jordan Peterson who's
someone that that community really
detest has grown so big because they
kept trying to protest his views and
because they try to silence and people
took more of an interest and so you
don't even realize it but it's like
you're fostering they're grown over you
doing the opposite people didn't even
know that Jordan Peterson was not be
because of you didn't know who he is and
are now following him makes them a
martyr no matter what their views are
you want to cancel someone you make them
a martyr yeah
[Music]
you know what the irony is is that
despite being a very marginalized group
in having real props that I actually
agree with you are actually perceived
from a marketing standpoint as bullies I
don't agree with that but I can agree
that some of the attacks that you employ
do have that feel to them and so let's
say it was another person that was
trying to speak and I wasn't even
interested in what they had to say but I
heard you screaming at them like that
and borrowed them then I would
immediately start taking issues like hey
why are you doing this to this person
where are they trying to say and I would
take time and because they're being calm
throughout this whole interaction and
you're being erratic then what I'm
perceiving in that moment is that oh I
feel probably trust this person because
this person seems unstable
they seem very angry and I don't
understand what's going on and so that's
what's happened in every single day so
if you want to have the progress that
you cling to you want to have maybe the
attack T star you're employed aren't the
best we always have to do this now no
we're not saying is I don't want to do I
do not want us to always have to say hey
we think you're humans hey we think
you're a good pilot I don't think we
should have to do that every single time
in order to have a conversation that's
difficult people they're not that smart
then they can live with it and they can
make whatever assumptions they want
because this will broke even when you
make those disclaimers they still make
assumptions and that's the facts so I
think it's Matt when we have to know
that yeah no no I just because I'm
having a difficult conversation I
disagree with you I somehow have to
always reaffirm your humanity for you
for us to have that okay they're not so
bad that if you are such a baby
that you can't handle the fact that
we're talking
about something and that we disagree
with you and you have to immediately go
to oh these guys are phobic oh they want
to deny my humanity then you're not
interesting to having conversation and I
don't need to talk to you that's it
because I want you to respond to what I
said not what you're inferring based off
what I didn't say so if they wanna infer
that we don't want then let them infer
what they want that's not my job
so that's me that's not my job that's
what it is
you guys don't want to have a
conversation with it you guys don't want
to have a conversation with it because
you don't have the ball on one hand me
wanting a specific set of genitals makes
me shallow
and reduces people to their genitals and
it's unnecessary on the other trans
people are constantly trying to get
surgery in order to be the assigned
except they want to be and so I just
think it's interesting that on one hand
you say it's insignificant for me but
for you guys it's such an important
transition to half it's not all the
trans but yeah I get what you're saying
I mean they even differentiate between
post-op and pre-op so this post up in
pre-op is there never
like not vegans three often it's just
like they said you know they're top free
office not even gonna have a car but if
you're not gonna have the operation is
like I'm never off
alright I'm never off in on that
[Laughter]
[Music]